the NHS is warning of a triple demek
this winter with flu covered and Rising
emergency cases
figures out this morning show 344
patients a day were admitted to hospital
with flu last week this is 10 times the
number seen in the first week of
December 2021
1920 adult General and acute beds were
occupied over the last week with overall
occupancy levels at 95 percent and more
than 13 000 beds a day were occupied by
people who no longer needed one this is
up a quarter compared to the first week
of December last year well let's get
more of that story from our health
correspondent ashes Joshi and that last
figure out she's really just shows the
root of the problem there are so many
people in these beds that they can't get
new people in to treat them
the urgency in Social care is impacting
the entire NHS and that's been the case
for some time now and that's recognized
I think now by the government it's it's
announces fund to help NHS trusts and
their social Care Partners to be able to
move some of these Patients Out free up
the hospital beds to try and ease the
pressure on the NHS as it grapples with
what is turning out to be a very
difficult winter some of the other
figures that you've just read through
there that tells us flu season is
already here the number of patients in
hospitals with flu extremely high and
we've only just begun the start of flu
season so this is the the triple demick
that NHS leaders and health leaders have
been warning about for some time we have
coveted it's still around and it's still
impacting hospitals and Healthcare we
have the flu season underway we also
have this incredible pressure on
emergency departments and now we have
the Specter of Union action over the
next few weeks we'll hear tomorrow from
the nurses about the dates when they
announce what dates they'll be taking
industrial action that will impact
elective care routine appointments
they'll be pushed back so this pressure
that continues to build on the NHS is
certainly beginning to tell and
especially with flu the problem here is
there's an acute shortage of Pediatric
Intensive Care Unit beds flu impacts
mostly on children especially vulnerable
children with underlying health
conditions and the elderly I've been
speaking to pediatric consultants over
the past couple of days and they've been
telling me about a real shortage of beds
and some of these children having to
wait in emergency departments before
they can access their intensive care bed
so flu I think a lot of people are quite
dismissive about it or have been because
we haven't seen it over the last couple
of years because of the pandemic because
of mitigation measures because the
viruses haven't really been spreading
around because of social distancing as
well but now it's back and we were
expecting respiratory illnesses to
rebound and they certainly are and this
is what the Chief Operating Officer for
the Imperial Healthcare trust Claire
hook had to say about the pressures on
her trust over the winter
activity I think this year is about
seven percent up in terms of the number
of patients who are coming through our
accident and emergency departments and
but we're still at quite an early stage
of our sort of winter season so we would
expect to get much busier as the course
of the next few weeks go on and we are
expecting it to be particularly
challenging partly because of the
backlog of our elective work that we're
getting through and partly because of
the demand at the front door as well of
course as the potential around
respiratory illness covered flu Etc so
we're planning for a very very busy
winter
so we knew these pressures existed
already but it seems now looking at the
latest data this winter situation report
which is the first time this winter it's
been published should be published every
week on a Thursday from now on that will
give us a real indicator about just how
much pressure the NHS is coming under
thank you very much